[Music]
Disney Princesses are some of the most
beautiful women we know inside and
outside well what if they had enough of
all this and became villains instead
this is what Travis fell again for break
calm imagined when he made these
characters part of the scariest horror
films wait until you see what Belle
looks like as the wolf men she and the
beasts are meant to be together if this
is your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up get
ready to be shocked because today we are
showing you ten Disney Princesses
reimagined as villains Jasmine in The
Exorcist we all know the story of
Princess Jasmine who fell in love with a
street urchin after he saved her from
Jafar but what does Aladdin have to do
with a young teenager possessed by a
demon in the exercise the Disney movie
could have been different if the thief
didn't find a genie in the Cave of
Wonders
this artist imagined that he found
something a little more evil in this
secret place when the kind-hearted thief
rubbed the lamp the demon Pazuzu came
out of it instead and he decided to
possess the vulnerable Princess Jasmine
because he wanted to get closer to the
Sultan and become the ruler of Agrabah
now this magic carpet is not used to go
on romantic dates but to make sure
Jasmine doesn't go anywhere the
beautiful princess's face is mutilated
and vomit is coming out of her mouth
even the Catholic Church can't stop her
as she becomes what they feared the most
when Aladdin be able to save her we
believe he will do anything to protect
his soulmate even if it means being
possessed by the demon and risking his
life at least this will probably keep
you far away from Jasmine only someone
who really loves the princess will have
the courage to help her Merida in
child's play this princess was not a
girl like any other instead of waiting
to be saved by a man she wanted to be
the hero of her own destiny she competed
for her own hand in marriage and easily
bested the other candidates in an
archery contest but Chuckie from child's
play was not a doll like any other
either
instead of making children smile he made
everyone scream of terror what if these
two redhead character
became one the doll wanted to possess
Andy's body but what if Merida was the
one he was looking for which is already
exist in dun broch but this time instead
of turning people into bears the magic
would be used for criminal Charles Lee
ray to possess the young princess and
once she would come back home the bad
guy inside her would be ready to get rid
of everyone who stands in his way
as you can see Merida now has a knife in
her hand instead of a bow and arrow and
once again she won't let any man go near
her but this time the possessed princess
will make sure to scare them an outfit
so no one will ever want to marry her at
least Merida will get what she wanted
and become a strong independent woman
after all better be alone with them in
bad company Cinderella and Carrie the
princess and the young teenager both
lived a miserable life when they were
teenagers after her father passed away
Cinderella became a servant for her
stepmother and her evil stepsisters
Carrie was rejected and everyone made
fun of her because of her conservative
lifestyle but these two girls had one
thing in common their beauty and their
magic with the help of a fairy godmother
and a new friend
they both had the chance to go to the
ball both wearing a unique dress they
spent the night dancing with a man they
liked and everyone was jealous of the
love they shared
but what if Cinderella's story ended in
another way there would be no more
prince charming and no happily ever
after
the princess would find out that she was
invited to the ball just so her
stepsisters could make fun of her
as you can see Cinderella has just been
humiliated on stage in front of everyone
in the kingdom her sisters spilled blood
on her beautiful dress to remind the
princess of the day they all laughed at
her but this time the princess has
decided to seek revenge with the magic
of her fairy godmother she will make it
so no one will make fun of her ever
again and the prince will have to pay
the price - now this is the prom night
everyone will remember forever Mulan in
the ring we love to see this warrior as
the first Asian Disney princess but what
if she was part of one of the scariest
Japanese horror films the ring mulan
didn't want anyone to know that she was
a woman pretending to be a man she
didn't want to dishonor her family by
telling them that she didn't want to
marry a man but
become a warrior the ghost of Sadako
Yamamura on the opposite wanted everyone
to listen to her story or her life would
tragically end both of these women were
powerful even though they had to face
great challenges well what if this time
Mulan's secret was discovered too early
as the law states the woman would be
executed for hiding her identity in the
army and she would come back as a
vengeful ghost so everyone could know
that her life ended simply because she
was a woman mulan would ask disney to
make a movie about her and every person
who would see it would have to share it
with someone else otherwise the warrior
would come out of the television and
take care of them as you can see someone
didn't let anyone else watch the video
so Mulan is coming back to seek revenge
with her green skin purple bags under
her eyes and hair ruined by a rainy day
she's not the princess we used to know
erielle has Creature from the Black
Lagoon mermaids were some of the most
beautiful creatures we could find under
the sea their voice was irresistible
and any man fell in love with their
looks as soon as they saw them but there
were other things you could find in a
sea and this was not something Prince
Erik would like to marry the strange
amphibious humanoid frightened anyone he
met people attacked him and the creature
sought revenge on anyone who stood in
his way
but what if Ariel looked just as scary
as The Creature from the Black Lagoon
she would ask for legs in exchange for
her voice only a kiss of true love could
make her live happily ever after
but when Erik would find this strange
creature on the beach he would be scared
and run away without the ability to
speak The Little Mermaid wouldn't be
able to show him how nice she is the
Prince would only judge her by her look
and we have to admit that we would be
terrified too with her green skin fish
scales covering her body and huge mouth
this is certainly not a creature we
would like to kiss after three days she
would fail to approach anyone and would
be trapped by Ursula and they say that
looks don't matter Elsa and Anna in the
shining frozen is one of the most
popular Disney Princess movies and The
Shining is one of the greatest horror
films so what if we created a mashup of
these two movies Elsa and Anna were best
friends when they were kids and their
love is what saved their kingdom from
the blizzard the twins in the Stanley
Kubrick masterpiece had to stay
together - but not because of choice
because their life was taken away in the
hotel and they had to stay there forever
well what if the two princesses passed
away when they were kids - the incidents
that happened when they were kids would
have been more tragic than what we saw
in the movie and the two sisters would
be haunting the castle in arendelle
forever this time Elsa would use her
power to scare everyone but don't worry
they wouldn't want to hurt anyone but
seeing people running away in fear would
be their favorite activity as you can
see Elsa and Anna are still holding
hands even now that they are ghosts they
wear a ribbon of different colours
around their waists to remind us of the
dresses they used to wear but instead of
the smile they usually wear on their
face they're just staring blankly at
something in front of them this time we
have to admit that we preferred these
Disney characters when they were alive
Tiana in Candyman just like Tiana the
Candy Man used to be an ambitious
hard-working man he was quickly
successful and became a well-known
painter unfortunately at that time her
lovers father didn't want to see these
two together this is why someone cut his
painting hand and replaced it with a
hook his life was also taken away as he
was smeared with honey and stung by bees
and since that day started hunting
anyone who would call him five times in
front of a mirror but what did Tiana
sought revenge - after someone cut the
hand she used as a waitress she wouldn't
only be mad she would become crazy now
if any impatient customer would call her
five times while waiting at their table
her ghost would appear to take care of
them and this time she wouldn't be
smiling just look at her face in this
picture she doesn't seem really happy to
go to work today but fortunately there
is a happy ending to this story just
like the Candyman the princess will find
a man that looks like the lovers she had
years ago they will both disappear in a
fire and spend eternity together as
ghosts they thought that vengeful
spirits couldn't find love knowing can
resist Tiana alive or not
Aurora in Dracula the princess and the
vampire had two things in common they
loved sleeping during the day and they
didn't like sharp things
after all the spindle of a spinning
wheel made Aurora sleep for years and a
wooden stake in the heart was the best
way to get rid of him but what if the
princess became a vampire
his 16th birthday instead of sleeping
forever Maleficent could have been one
of these evil creatures who wanted the
young girl to be a part of her new
family and the years of sleep would
represent the years it would take for
Aurora to fully transform into a vampire
instead of a kiss of true love she would
wake up to bite the prince and make him
a vampire - but as you can see things
didn't go as she expected the princess
had the time to become a vampire with
her dark hair red eyes and bloody fangs
but this is how Prince Philip noticed
that she was not the girl he met in the
forest years ago instead of spewing her
heart he drove a wooden stake right into
it but we have to admit that using a
beautiful woman as prey is a good way to
attract the prince this plan almost
worked
Pocahontas and Friday the 13th the
Native American woman was the daughter
of the chief and nature's best friend
when she met European John Smith she
told me about all the beautiful things
he could find outside if he only looked
around him but what was more beautiful
to him was Pocahontas herself on the
opposite Jason probably didn't like
nature so much because he drowned in a
lake since that day he was out for
revenge but what do these two characters
have in common
probably nothing but this is not a
reason to not do a mash-up when she
would see that John Smith and his friend
are destroying the forest and want to
get rid of the Native Americans living
there she would become crazy she would
put on a mask find a sword and make sure
that these Europeans stay on their own
continent no love story is possible when
the guy you were dating is trying to
steal your land and pretending that they
discovered it as you can see from the
picture the princess is coming out of
the lake in which Jason passed away she
wants to defend nature and she would be
ready to do it at all cost the next time
her father wants to get rid of Smith she
won't stop him fell in wolfmen the
beauty was really surprised when she
first saw the beast and those who saw
the werewolf for the first time were
probably shocked - but what if these two
stories were actually related this might
explain why the prince became a hairy
and terrifying creature he was bitten by
a werewolf years ago and unfortunately
for him something probably went wrong
because
is a full-time beast but what if instead
of sharing a kiss of true love with
Belle he used his mouth to turn her into
a werewolf - they would be too
terrifying creatures living in a castle
and she would have nowhere else to go
when the full moon would be up in the
night sky as you can see from the
picture the night of the ball didn't end
up so well this is when beast decided to
bite her and turn Belle into a werewolf
and the transformation doesn't seem very
enjoyable at least this time Gaston will
probably stay far away from her he loved
her for her beauty and now that he can't
appreciate the amazing personality that
is hidden underneath all this hair at
least the Beast will understand what
it's like to scare everyone and the two
will live happily ever after alone in
their castle and that's it for 10 Disney
Princesses reimagined as villains which
one would you like to see in a movie
mashup don't forget to tell us in the
comments and for more stories like this
don't forget to subscribe to the things
and watch 10 Disney Princesses
reimagined by amazing artists thanks for
watching
[Music]